the secret service which protects
presidents and cabinet officers
has just released a study of school
shootings and how to stop them
the agency's national threat assessment
center analyzed nearly 70 disrupted
school plots
over the past two decades now the study
found the key to stopping them was
early intervention by someone close to a
student that was possibly planning the
violence
senior investigative correspondent
catherine herridge spoke to one school
safety advocate
he's more worried now about the students
heading back to classroom because of the
pandemic's impact
on mental health he lost his own
daughter in a school shooting
three years ago targeted school attacks
frequently occur
after we've had a absence
we know that kovit has given many
students and schools
the longest break in attendance they've
ever had tony montalto lost his daughter
gina three years ago
when a former student killed 17 people
and wounded
17 more at marjory stoneman douglas high
school in parkland florida
gina was my forever 14 year old daughter
today with millions of kids learning
virtually and not in the classroom
some students lost their support network
and mental health services
some students sadly have not been in a
nurturing and
comfortable environment through the
crisis as they
learn from home the new secret service
report said
students who plotted attacks shared many
similarities with students who carried
out
violent attacks they had histories of
school discipline
and contact with law enforcement they
experienced bullying or had mental
health issues
and used drugs or alcohol the report
concluded school violence
is preventable when communities identify
warning signs and intervene
early intervention is key dr lina
alithari and her team at the secret
service analyzed
nearly 70 plots that were reported and
averted between 2006 and 2018
classmates were among the first to
observe the warning signs
in this report we've seen that students
were the most positioned
to come forward with this information
after the 1999 columbine shooting the
secret service studied school safety
the attacks that we studied in averting
targeted school violence were
really serious in nature if you look at
how far they got in their planning
and the situation this really could have
presented serious harm
the parkland shooter had a long history
of emotional and disciplinary problems
montalto is now president of stand with
parkland
a group pushing for school safety and
gun reforms
were a lot of warning signs missed yes
many warning signs were missed there
were over 40 interactions with him
and the local law enforcement everybody
knew what a danger he was
the report identified other concerning
behaviors including an interest in
violent or hate-filled topics
and a fixation on mass shootings like
columbine montalto says his daughter
would have been graduating
part of the class of 2021. their family
has channeled its grief
into action it doesn't lessen the pain
but allows us an avenue to work through
and something to work towards rather
than
and possibly dwell in our grief
constantly
the secret service tells cbs news that
every school is different and needs a
plan that meets its unique needs
the new report is a starting point
adriana
catherine thank you this is just
heartbreaking i mean we covered parkland
so extensively and then the reaction
after school spending millions of
dollars on bulletproof
glass and bunkers and classrooms but
really it's if you see something say
something and that's most effective
students speaking up that are saving
lives and first thank you to tony
montalto because you
as a parent as a parent you just can't
imagine the grief that he's feeling but
to figure out a way to try to channel
that into something
but you know kids are so i don't want to
tell on anybody we have to get rid of
that i don't want to tell
you now's the time to tell you can no
longer take it lightly when somebody
says i'm mad and i'm going to do
something
exactly so hopefully kids are learning
that